czechia is facing one of the most
difficult situations in europe right now
the number of coronavirus cases is
rising rapidly
and it needs medical equipment to treat
patients and hospitals
we do not leave our european friends
alone in these hard
times therefore the european commission
is mobilizing medical material
through our civil protection mechanism
i just called the prime minister andrei
babish
to tell him that we are dispatching
rapidly
to czechia a set of 30 ventilators from
our rescue reserve
and we are in touch with other eu
countries
to mobilize more ventilators for the
czech republic
we are in this together